I've not seen a lot of these these gqm
tell you stories by imagine sometimes
people will give you a really far-out
story about why they've got their
tattoos not gonna be a lot of that here
a lot of these are just random but
there's none that I regret like that one
on my ass hi I'm Lou Thomason I'm here
with GQ today to talk through some of my
tattoos I said to anyone who knew me I'd
never have a tattoo and I've never
smoked cigarettes in real life on a
different way and the first tattoo that
I got and I thought it was going to be
the only one I recognized about 20 21
around that time when we're in the band
we agreed that we would all have
matching tattoos and our ankles have
just like crosses basically and we all
then got it done except for nail but we
did actually all agree that we'd do them
all together but now I never got is done
just it's a stag is it I'm sold again no
no reasoning behind it wanted something
big for me arm and and that's why I got
it I have a heart above it and then this
were a really bad side because the only
cover-up I've ever a touch to this one
really weird like a heart and I'd like
headphones we like horrible horrible
horrible decision but that's the beauty
of a good cover-up I think almost by
accident especially yeah it's almost a
bit like sketch pad notepad kind of vibe
you know what I mean and most of these
are done in different places different
cities different countries different
ability of tattoo artists you know I
mean this is probably my worst tattoo
even though it's pretty small and it's
not great quality amongst army tattoos
but this is pretty horrific the lines
aren't straight it was meant to be an X
I mean I look so out there put my finger
over it take it away
horrible horrible Robbie Williams the
two of us run the expert discover judges
and I think we've been joking before on
the panel saying we should tattoo each
other so we did add X as each I put an X
on him
not gonna lie did a pretty good job and
then I'll let him have a go and he's
yeah he's made a horrible jump on that
if I'm being honest
compass absolutely no no meaning behind
that one and it done in LA this is one
of the better ones to be fair you turn
it this way it goes 3b its way to do you
know at me a bit like it points to home
which it in that swing you know I mean
this looks skateboarder ear I used to
like scape on a little bit when I was
younger so I thought I think maybe I
seen this on Google I was like yeah
right I'll start with that and then I
just got this really ugly lie underneath
it and I remember you know before I had
all the tattoos there it looked pretty
gross that that's the skateboarding man
I got to tell you myself in like maybe
two years now except for I've got a
really comical penguin on my ass which I
won't be showing it just it times I'm
not gonna lie I can tell be a bit of a
show-off that were what at the moment
this would be funny watch this and then
I have to live for here this bird ear in
terms of style and like art and that
this guy did a great job and this is one
of the only tattoo shops that I've been
into that there's a vibe in there you
know I mean they're moody light
unapproachable and I'm like okay I'm in
a proper place here walking I thought
right okay be proper organise our show
guy was like this is exactly what I want
and it was a picture of this guy's arm
and I was like this guy is sick I want
this he'll eat such chuckling this guy
in my house is bit embarrassing that
what's he laughing at goes and gets his
mate from behind wherever and that's in
is made this is made some and I've just
been like saying this guy so cool I have
up one there and you know that just
proper just sold myself out for this guy
and he's cool too Oh bog I swear to God
I had completely I have not looked at
this - OH
cuz it's blended in underneath me rope a
little bit and literally have not looked
at these for years
yes what are they couldn't tell you I
don't know I barely even remember having
it never mind why and look at these look
birds now as were thinking again I don't
[ __ ] know what tattoos I've got
I had a very violent past no that is
absolutely no reason behind that there's
about 100 tattoos that are pretty common
I'd say Doug is one of them and I've
just seen it on a few different people a
few different pitches how about that
oh this what this one is a little bit
sentimental actually says given a chance
and yeah it's a lyric of Kings of Leon
song and when I were younger before I
was in the band you know you always like
to put a little bit on your bio is like
a bit of a lyric and that and it was
that lyric so I kind of for taking that
on the mix the end cause there that says
that and this says rolled and that would
name me band that was in before one
direction I really could those just
kicked me out the band but still I'm the
bigger man and I will get it tattooed on
my body they all there anyone who's
saying they don't know it's [ __ ] and
they all love it and I always liked just
before I get in chair and like give the
guy a bit of a disclosure but I look
like I am a bit of a wimp with pain
it's not as if I have searched across
the country or globe to find the right
artist on any of these to be honest it's
only after the event in your skin starts
getting used to it that you realize how
bad some of these are what I need is I
need a full day just going into some
proper camp tattoo guy and you could
just fix me off it's been quite a fun
journey for me not taking it too
seriously getting tattoos because most
people second really seriously you know
I mean spend months over working on the
exact one and I'll give you like a
far-out story about what the bird means
it's freedom and all that but I thing
just get to tap you shop and decide when
you're there